antoine bonjour alors que faut-il
retenir de cette réunion
et bien tout d'abord plusieurs chiffres
la vice-premier ministre en charge du
dossier a commencé par annoncer les
derniers chiffres plus de quarante sept
mille personnes sont infectées avec une
hausse de 10 % de nouveaux cas ces
dernières 24 heures ont la main pour un
bilan humain à l'heure actuelle qui
s'élève à 4 105 morts ensuite mis
l'accent sur les efforts fournis en
russie sur le dépistage de la maladie en
effet en date d'aujourd'hui plus de 2
millions de tests ont été effectués
c'est actuellement le deuxième pays le
plus testé au monde
en agissant de la sorte c'est à dire en
multipliant les tester en identifiant
les malades qui n'ont pas de symptômes
les autorités sanitaires espère
combattre plus efficacement la
propagation de la maladie
du côté de la prévention et de la
protection vladimir poutine a fait
savoir que la production quotidienne de
masques en russie allait prochainement
passer de 3,5 à 7 millions sans parler
des masques importés depuis la chine en
particulier car le plus dur reste encore
à venir tous je vous propose de
l'écouter
nous arrivons à maintenir l'objectif de
la première étape de décisions
c'est-à-dire de freiner cette évolution
mais il ne faut pas s'arrêter là
comme le disent les spécialistes vous et
vos collègues
le pic de l'épidémie est encore à venir
et nous devons faire le maximum pour
simplifier tout ça toute cette situation
il limitait le nombre de nouvelles de
nouveaux malades et ne travaillant sur
dans toutes les directions là dessus
mais à partir de la semaine prochaine un
fonds spécialisé dédié pour de lits
d'hôpitaux spécialisées supplémentaires
va être affectée et je le répète ici
tous les scénarios possibles doivent
être envisagées
toujours durant cette réunion de travail
vladmir poutine a demandé aux experts
les différentes projections de
l'évolution de la maladie à plusieurs
échéances à 3 7 10 30 jours afin de
mettre à jour et prendre en
considération tous les scénarios
possibles
il a aussi tenu à rappeler que les
mesures de confinement et de semaine de
travail chômé depuis le début du mois
d'avril avait permis de gagner du temps
et surtout de ne pas connaître une
hausse brutale de nouveaux cas merci
antoine pour toutes ces précisions
antoine claireaux en direct de moscou